مشاهدينا من عمان ينضموا الى المتحدث باسم
منظمه اليونسيف في الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا محمد الحوالي
التغطيه بدايه ما هو تقييم اليونيسيفر
الاولي
لتداعيات هذا الزلزال في المناطق السوريه
المتضرره
في الحقيقه هو امر جلل بل يعتبر كما قيل
انه المصيبه الاكبر او الكارثه الاكبر منذ
100 عام على هذه المنطقه عدد المباني
المهدمه البنيه التحتيه التي تضررت بشكل
كبير حتى بالاضافه الى رقم المدارس التي
ذكرتموه فقد تضاعف العدد اكثر من ذلك بحيث
انه لا يوجد رقم دقيق لكنه وصل قرابه ال
500 مدرسه قد تكون تضررت بالاضافه الى
الضرر الرئيسي في شبكات توصيل المياه
الصالحه للشرب وخزانات المياه وايضا الى
مرافق الصرف الصحي وهذه هي في الحقيقه
اليوم هي الاولويه الاولى لدينا بان يكون
هناك وصول سهل للمياه الصالحه للشرب لانه
نحن لا نريد ان يكون هناك اي كوارث وبائيه
تحديدا بعد هذه الكارثه التي فقد الكثير
ارواحهم فيها لذلك تقييم الموضع انه
ماساوي صعب جدا يحتاج الك والكثير من
التظافر والتعاون حتى نصل الى مرحله شبه
مرضيه لحال هؤلاء الناس طيب ولا يخفى
عليكم بان المنطقه ككل هي متدربه بسبب عدد
مرات النزوح واللجوء فيها وهناك نقص
مستدام للمساعدات بل ان اكثر من مليون
و300 الى مليون و700 الف طفل في المنطقه
هم يعانون من شتى انواع الحياه الغير
صالحه للاستمرار سواء كان بسبب فقر الدم
او التقزم او الهزال وهناك اكثر من 500
الف امراه في نصف مليون امراه يعني
المجالات التي تقدموه فيها المساعدات قبل
هذه الاطفال كبيره وواسعه بالتاكيد لكن
عطفا على تداعيات هذا الزلزال وما
شاهدتموحه على الارض يعني ما هو الدعم
الاكبر الذي يحتاجه الاطفال في هذا
التوقيت وانتم مؤسسه او منظمه تعنى في
المقام الاول بالاطفال
بعد ما يخص ابي الرعايه الصحيه الاوليه
فيما يخص وصول المياه الصالحه للشرب وايضا
توفير دعم فرق العلاج الصحيه على الارض
وامكانيه وصولها لاماكن متضررين ياتي امر
مهم جدا وهو حمايتهم ودعمهم النفسي
الحمايه تنقسم الى عده اقسام منها رعايه
من فقدوا والديهم وذويهم وهناك اطفال
فقدوا جميع اسرهم بالكامل فنحن تعدينا
مرحله اليتم الى اللطم وبالتالي هذه مشكله
مهمه جدا يجب احتوائها وتسيطر عليها من
خلال توفير فرق الدعم النفسي من خلال
المراكز المجتمعيه الموجوده على الارض
وايضا من خلال مساعداتنا التي استطعنا
بايصال في الشمال الغرب السوري احد
الحوافلات المخصصه لتوفير كل ما هو لازم
للدعم النفسي الدعم النفسي بعد الاحداث
التي مثل هذه هو امر مهم جدا تحديدا
وخصوصا القصه وخصوصا للقصر الذين فقدوا
اوليائهم الاطفال هؤلاء هم بحاجه ماسه جدا
لكل ما هو ممكن من الدعم النفسي حتى
يستطيعوا الاستمرار في الحياه كلنا يعلم
ان هناك بوصله بشريه لكل انسان عندما تصبح
حادثه معينه قد تفقد الادراك بما حوله
وهذا الامر يتضاعف تحديدا عند الاطفال
خصوصا في مثل هذه الكوارث العظيمه للاسف
طيب ماذا عن قدرتكم على الوصول الى مختلف
المناطق الواقع تحت سيطره مختلفه الاطراف
داخل سوريا في ظل تعنت بعضها في السماح
للمساعدات بالمرور الى مره اخرى
بسبب طول الازمه تحديدا في تلك المناطق
يوجد لدينا اكثر من 17
يعني شريك على محلي على الارض يعمل
بفاعليه وهذا يجعل ايصال المساعدات ممكننا
لجميع ومختلف المناطق سواء كان من خلال
قوافل الامميه التي تاتي من معبر باب
الهوى او من مناطق الاخرى حسب اتفاقيه
الامم المتحده لكن المبشر والمطمئن ان هنا
هؤلاء الشركاء على الارض هم حقيقه يعني
يستطيعوا الوصول الى غالب الاسر المتضرره
يعني نحن اليوم نسعى الى الوصول الى الى
خمسه الاف اسره في كل جوله من حيث توفير
اللوازم الاساسيه لاستمرار الحياه هناك
مثلا ما يسمى بالبسكويت المقوى اللي هو
يحتوي على فيتامينات اساسيه للمسانده نحن
نحاول توفيره الى جميع المتضررين حسب
تقديرات مفوضيه اللاجئين كما تعلمون هناك
5.3 مليون
الانسان اصبحوا ما بين نازح ولاجئ في نفس
هذه المنطقه هؤلاء بحاجه الى المسانده في
كل ما نستطيعه توفير لهم من خلال
مستودعاتنا حول العالم المستودعات
الموجوده الاحتياطيه الطارئه في داخل
المنطقه لا تكفي لهذا الحجم الكبير من
المتضررين بالتالي نحن نستعين بكل ما
لدينا من قدرات مخزنه وايضا من خلال
المناشده التي سنطلقها قريبا بالاحتياج
الكامل لاننا ما زلنا في هذه المرحله نقيم
الاضرار لان المصاب جلل والامكانيه الوصول
ليست بالسهله لكل مكان سواء بسبب العوائق
التي تتعلق من جراحه التربه واغلاق الطرق
او من خلال العدم الوصول والمرور من حدودي
الى حدود اخرى لذلك اليوم نحن في مرحله
تقييم اساسيه بالاضافه الى عملنا المباشر
على الارض من خلال الايصال المساعدات
الممكنه لكننا سنكون على درايه اكثر خلال
الايام القليله هذه النقطه بحجم
نستطيع المسانده اسمح لي ايضا
حريصين اليوم على ايصال المياه الصالحه
للشرب وتوفير الخدمات الممكنه والمسانده
الممكنه للفرق الصحيه على هذه النقطه اللي
كنت تسمعني او ايضا ان اعود بك نقطه اخرى
اثرت مهمه جدا الاطفال الذين لم يعد لهم
اي اقارب على قيد الحياه حاليا بسبب هذا
الزلزال ما هي خططكم لرعايه هؤلاء الاطفال
وبطبيعه الحال هم يحتاجون الى رعايه طويله
الامد
الدول التي حدثت فيها هذه الكارثه في
الداخل التركي توجد هناك مؤسسات حكوميه هي
قائمه وفاعله في رعايه الاطفال الذين
فقدوا ذويهم
وما الى ذلك من الحمايه القانونيه
والحمايه الاجتماعيه من شبكه الحمايه
الاجتماعيه وهذا ما هو نفعله في داخل
الاراضي في شمال السوري او في الشمال
الشرقي او في الغرب وان كان لان هناك اكثر
من 500 مركز مجتمعي او يزيد عن ذلك الرقم
حقيقه هم عبر البلاد كلهم مستعدين ومهيئين
لاستضافه والتعامل مع هذه الحالات حمايه
حق الطفل هو مناط بكل دوله يكون فيها هذا
الطفل ونحن دورنا ان نحرص على ان تطبق هذه
الانظمه بشكل صحيح وان يكون هناك في شبكه
حمايه مجتمعيه من شانها ان تحمي هؤلاء
الاطفال
وتحافظ على حتى نرى في المستقبل لاحقا كيف
سيتم احتضانهم
ورعايتهم والتعليم هم غيرهم يعني هو ليست
من الامور اللي بدري نحكي عنها بس احنا
لازم نتكلم ايضا عن اعاده تشغيل المدارس
في اقرب وقت ممكن لذلك يجب تقييم الاضرار
في المركز التعليميه والبنيه التحتيه
التعليميه حتى تعود وتستمر لان هذا امر
مهم ان نحافظ على هذه الاجيال انها تفقد
في داخل ما هي ابرز الجهات او الدول التي
تتواصلون معها وتقدم لكم الدعم والتسهيل
في هذه الظروف الصعبه لتقديم هذه
المساعدات للمحتاجين في شمال سوريا
في الحقيقه
ساذكر لك موقف هو هو يعني مؤثر بان وصلتني
يوم البارحه رساله البريد الالكتروني ان
هناك فتاه تربي قطط دخلها لا يتجاوز
المئتين دولار تبرعت بهذا المبلغ كله حتى
تساند هؤلاء المحتاجين فنحن نتكلم عن اصغر
فئات المجتمع الى اعظم الدول في العالم
سواء كانت دول الخليج المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وغيرها من الدول الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والاتحاد الاوروبي كل
يحاول تقديم المساعده الممكنه لكن نحن
ذكرت انفا باننا سنطلق
ذكرت السابق سوف نطلق حمله واضحه المعالم
هناك احتياج المالي
اللازم وهو لازم لماذا واين وكيف ومتى
سيتم التعامل معه لانه ما زالت الكارثه
قائمه ما زالت عمليه الانقاذ والامل في
ايجاد احياء مازال قائم
للاسف المخصصات العالميه في كثير من الدول
للعمل الانساني قلت ومنذ سنوات والتمويل
اللازم
للعمليات الاستجابه سواء كان للنازحين او
للدول ذات الاقتصاديات الهشه هو غير كافي
ودائما في نسبه عجز ليست بالبسيطه الرقم
الذي ذكرتموه نحن لم نستطيع توفير الثلث
منه لكن الان مع التقييم الحاله الحاليه
والاحتياج بكل تاكيد سيكون اكبر من ذلك
بكثير
لكننا نعول على ان يكون هناك في استجابه
حقيقيه وجاده من الجميع لانه الكل
مسه هذا الضرر الكل بشعره به الكل تفاعل
معه
وبالتالي لعل يعني بكل تاكيد ستكون
مناشدتنا مباشره وواضحه ونامل حقيقه بان
يتم توفير المبلغ اللازم حتى نحمي هذا
الجيل القادم
من هذا من هذا الضرر الكبير الضرر منه من
فقد احبابه فقدوا منازلهم مدارسهم البنيه
التحتيه يعني بكل شتى انواع
المتطلبات الحياه البسيطه الكريمه اختفت
للاسف في خلال هذه الازمه نامل ان نستطيع
ان نعيد ولو جزء منها رسالتك وصلت وشكرا
لك على وجودك معنا من عمان كنت معا
المتحدث باسم منظمه اليونسيف في الشرق
الاوسط وشمال افريقيا السيد محمد الحواري
شكرا جزيلا لك